But any other questions on the trinity?
>> No, no, that's it. Uh, thank you for the
time.
>> No, but before you go, brother, I want
to leave you some words and I want you
to do me a favor. I want to leave you
some words, my brother humanity. I'm
going to give you some words of Jesus
before you leave. You're going to write
them down, but I'm going to read them
for you. I want you to go to your Bible
when I read them and then you write them
down. And I want you to show me anything
similar in the Quran. Okay? I'm just
gonna give you a few. You ready?
>> Uh, okay. Hold on.
I'll I'll mention them and I'll put them
in the private chat and I'll read them
for you. All right.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Okay. Let me let me show you this. Okay.
Matthew 11:27
to30. Matthew 11 27-30. But let me line
them up for you. Hold on. I'm going to
get them all for you. So I don't want to
overwhelm you. Okay. Watch here. Let me
just do this.
So I don't overwhelm you. I'm just going
to give you a few now. But there's a
couple of more before you leave. Matthew
11 27-30.
That's the Gospel of Matthew 11 27-30.
John 11. I'm going to put a private chat
for you right here. John 11:es 20- 27.
Private chat. You'll see it's there.
John 14:es 1-6.
John 14 18-19. I just want to read some
before you leave because I want to leave
with this. Now you have me you go back
and reread them and try to find anything
like this in the Quran. Anything. And if
you come next time if you're open I want
to show you the difference between what
the Quran says about Muhammad
and what Jesus says in the Gospels. Let
me know when you want to do that when
you have more time. Okay. Are you ready
for me to read these?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So your duty is you're going to
try to find something like this in your
Quran. Okay. Here it is. This is Jesus
speaking. Matthew 11:27:30.
All things have been committed to me by
my father.
Everything was given to me by my father.
That's why we're turnarians. We don't
believe he's the father. No one knows
the son except the father. No one knows
the father except the son and those to
whom the son chooses to reveal him. So
Jesus says, "No one knows who I truly am
except my father. And no one knows my
father except me, which is why I have to
make him known.
Okay. So, and yet in your Quran, Allah
is not a father. Jesus is not a son.
You're not even a son. Yet, Jesus says,
"God is my father. I'm his son. I own
everything that belongs to him and I
alone know him and I alone can make him
known." And this is why he makes an
invitation then because I alone can make
him known. He says this, "Come to me.
Come to me
all you who are weary and burdened. All
of you who are tired,
come to me and I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you and learn from me.
For I am gentle and humble in heart and
you will find rest for your souls. I
will give you rest. For my yoke is easy
and my burden is light. Show me
something close to this what Jesus said.
But let me give you another one.
One of Jesus's best friends, Lazarus,
had died.
His sister is crying. His sisters are
crying and they hear Jesus coming. Now
watch here. John 11 20-27.
John 11 20-27. Watch this.
John 11:207.
When Martha heard that Jesus was coming,
she went out to meet him. But Mary
stayed at home. Lord Martha said to
Jesus, "If you had been here, my brother
would not have died. But I know that
even now God, meaning the father, his
father, will give you whatever you ask."
Now watch what Jesus says to her. Now I
want you to find me any prophet in your
Quran or in the Old Testament, Muhammad
speaking like this. Show me any prophet,
right? Speaking like this. Look what
Jesus says. Jesus said to her, "Your
brother will rise again."
Now she's thinking that oh yama on the
day of judgment. All right. Now watch.
So what does she say? John 11:20-27.
Martha answered, "I know he will rise
again in the resurrection at the last
day." Now I want you to show me Muhammad
or anyone in your Quran that speaks like
this, a mere prophet. Jesus said to her,
"I am the resurrection and the life."
So let me repeat it again. I am the
resurrection, the life. I myself am the
resurrection and the life. The one who
believes in me will live even though
they die.
And whoever lives by believing me will
never die. Do you believe this? And then
I can show in the Quran where Allah says
to Muhammad, if you believe it's Allah,
you will die and they will die. That's
chapter 39:30 of the Quran. Or where
Allah tells Muhammad to say in chapter
46:9 46:9
say I am new no new fangle thing among
the apostles. I am but a warner. I do
not know what Allah will do with me or
with you. I do not know what Allah will
do with me or with you. 46:9.
Chapter 46:9. And yet Jesus says, I am
the resurrection, the life. You believe
in me, you will never die. But then he
says, do you believe this?
And then watch what she says. Give you
one more and then if you have question,
you don't need to go. But let me just
give you this. It's up to you. You want
to say that more? You can ask me more.
But here, look what she says then. Yes,
Lord.
She replied, I believe that you are the
Messiah, the son of God who is to come
into the world, not a mere prophet.
You are the son of God. So I believe
what you said. And what did he say? I am
the resurrection, the life. Show me a
prophet that says that the final one.
And if you have more questions, you
don't need to go. But let me just read
this final one. John 14. And I gave you
the verses there. You can read them on
your own. John 14:es
1-6
John 14:es 1-6
Jesus speaking do not let your hearts be
troubled you believe in God the father
that's what he means God believe also in
me now look at his promise this is his
promise my father's house has many rooms
if that were not so
what I have told you that I'm going
there to prepare a place for You see,
I'm going there to prepare a place for
you. I'm going to make you a home. I
want to make you a home. And now watch
his promise. And if I go and prepare a
PLACE FOR YOU, I will come back and take
you to be with me that you also may be
with me where I am. Show me any prophet
in the Quran that says this. I'm
preparing a place for you in Jenna and I
will come and take you to Jenna. Jesus,
I'm preparing homes for you and I will
come and take you. Now, look what he
says. You know the way to the place
where I am going. Now, Thomas, one of
the disciples, is like confused because
they still don't understand what he's
talking about. Look what he says. Look
what Jesus says. John 14:es 1-6. What he
says,
look what he says here. Thomas said to
him,"Lord, we don't know where you are
going. So, how can we know the way?
They're not getting it. Now, here again,
I want to challenge you. Go spend as
much time you need. Show me a single
verse in the Quran where Muhammad or any
prophet in the Quran says what Jesus
says about himself. Jesus answered, "I
am the way
and the truth." Al the Quran says this
is the name of God only and the life. He
goes, "I am the life." No prophet says I
am the life. Show that to me. You will
not find it the Old Testament. Not going
to find the Quran. No prophet says, "I
am the life." The Quran says, "Allah is
the life. He's the truth." And yet here
Jesus supposedly a man, no more than a
man. I am the truth and the life. I am
the way. No one comes to the father
except through me. Now notice the
difference between your religion and
mine. And I got two more verses.
In your Quran, you cannot call Allah
your father. You can't say, "Oh, my
father."
And you cannot call yourself his son.
Jesus says, "I am the son of God, and
I'm going to bring you to my father."
And we're told if we believe in him, we
become sons and daughters of God. Now,
let me ask you an honest question.
How can you tell me someone who believes
in the Bible, who believes the Bible is
not corrupt,
that the God of the Quran is the same
God where in the Bible I'm told Jesus is
the son of God and if I believe in him,
he'll make me a son of God and I can
call God my father. Whereas the Quran,
Allah is not a father. I can't call him
a father. I'm a slave. How can you tell
me it's the same God? Be honest with me.
How can it be?
>> It's not right.
>> It's not. It's not the same God.
>> You got it. Now watch the final part.
John 14:18 to19. Final part. This is
what he says.
I will not leave you as orphans.
This is his promise. He cannot lie. He
said, "I'm the truth. I cannot lie. I'm
the life. I will give you life. I will
not leave you as orphans. I will come to
you. Before long, the world will not see
me anymore because now he's in heaven.
But you will see me. Now notice his
promise. Because I live, you also will
live. Guys can't lie. He goes, I am the
way. And yet you Muslims pray, guide us
on the straight path. Jesus says, well,
I am the straight path. I am the way and
I am the life. Believe me, I'll give you
life and I'll bring you to my father.
and you will not be an orphan because I
won't leave you alone. Now you got these
verses. Now you know where to find the
Bible and I want you to go and show me
something close to what the Bible says,
what the Quran says that Allah is a
father that I can say,
"Oh Allah, you are my father." That's
heresy. I can't say that. And yet Jesus
says he is the son of God and that his
father is my father when I believe in
him and I can know he loves me with a
perfect love. He loves me as a son.
You can't give me that in Islam. So why
would I want to leave Jesus for Islam?
Come on man. I hope you leave it but man
you want to stay. You can keep it. I can
never leave this Jesus and these words.
I am the resurrection life. Come to me
and I will give you rest. I am the way
and the truth and the life. I'm making a
home for you. I will not leave you as
orphans.
You want me to leave this for Islam? I
don't think so. I hope you leave Islam.
But anyway, if you have any questions,
feel free. If not, you need to come
back. You know where to find me.
>> Okay, sounds good.
>> Okay, you reach out to me when you want
to talk more, especially about Jesus and
Muhammad and their words from the Quran
and the Bible and see the difference.
So, let me know. All right. I appreciate
your time. Thank you.
>> Take care, Ysef.
>> You too. Bye. Bye.
>> Okay. Pray for Yousef. Now, you see
again, brethren,
you see again, my precious sisters,
why you should not marry non-Christians.
This man's mother is a Catholic and his
father is a secular sunny Muslim.
This man's mother is a Catholic
and his dad is a Muslim by name. She's a
Catholic by name. And you see the
confusion. He became Shia Muslim.
You see, you cannot get married just for
yourself.
Marriage is not just about you. Love
your neighbor as yourself. Do unto
others as you'd have them do unto you.
Marriage is not just about you and your
spouse. It's about the family that you
will have for the glory of Christ. Do
not marry outside of your faith because
you're going to confuse your children
and you'll be responsible if they lose
their way.